[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis wenn
heute gibt es ein leckeres brot rezepte
und zwar werden wir denken und das
dinkelbrot besteht zu 100 aus dinkel
also das ist kein weizen noch können
rocken mit dabei wirklich 100 winkel
dinkla die besondere eigenschaft das ist
biologisches eiweiß enthält das heißt es
kann vom körper direkt aufgenommen
werden und ich deswegen auch wirklich
selbst sehr gut vor allem einfach mal
ein toller eine tolle alternative zur
üblichen brot die dinkel kölner habe ich
selbst gemahlen und den teig bereits
gestern hergestellt das heißt auch bei
diesem put rezept ist einfach warten
den teig am vortag herzustellen das sind
zwei teile und zwar habe ich einmal ins
zeug und einmal ein bruchstück und da
erkläre ich euch gleich was es ist
zuerst einmal zeige ich euch mal die
benötigten zutaten
ich brauche insgesamt 430 gramm dinkel
körner für dinkelvollkornbrot fünf
company für wasser hier habe ich noch 95
gramm dinkel körner für
dinkelvollkornbrot ein gramm salz und
140 gramm wasser ich werde jetzt erst
einmal den sauerteig herstellen dafür
brauche ich denken vollkornmehl und das
werde ich jetzt hier aus diesem winkel
können und natürlich nehme ich auch mein
hefe wasser das habe ich selbst
angesetzt und da findet ihr das rezept
für bereits auf einem kanal für den
vorteig brauche ich jetzt nicht die
kompletten 430 gramm vollkornmehl aber
ich werde es trotzdem jetzt in einem zug
machen damit ich morgen einfach nicht
nochmal mehl mahlen muss das heißt die
kammern kommen jetzt hier rein und die
werden jetzt fein gemahlen und ein video
zur getreidemühle zur benutzung zur
reinigung und zur pflege findet ihr
bereits auf einem kanal
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier das fein gemahlene
mehl und jetzt nehme ich mir ein
schraubglas sollte groß genug sein denn
der soundtrack da geht ja auch ein
bisschen auf das heißt ich entnehme
jetzt 105 gramm nähe und den rest beweis
einfach für morgen auf das heißt ich
brauche morgen nicht extra nochmal mehl
mahlen habe ich jetzt heute schon gut
vorbereitet und ich kann es nur wieder
sagen wir mal im letzten video der
frisch gemahlenes mehl das riecht
einfach unglaublich lecker also ich muss
echt sagen ich werde niemals wieder
vollkommen kaufen ich mache das immer so
da kommt jetzt das hefe wasser dazu was
auch schon sehr lecker riecht jetzt
alles kurz verrühren
[Musik]
dafür schließlich ist das glas und lass
das jetzt einfach bei raumtemperatur
etwa 12 bis 15 stunden stehen das schön
jetzt hier auf ein tablett und kann
jetzt schon das frühstück vorbereiten
und dieses mail das brauche ich
natürlich auch erst morgen also kommt es
hier auch zur seite und jetzt nämlich
die übrigen bedingte volk die linke
kölner bin ich selber schon ganz
durcheinander und werde jetzt daraus
folgt rot zu bereiten das heißt ich muss
jetzt die mühle umstellen es ist ja
gerade auch sehr fein eingestellt und
jetzt stelle ich sie etwa bis auf die
mitte ein
dann die körner wieder oben rein jetzt
eine schüssel hunter und damit ihr sehen
könnt was ich da gerade mache will ich
jetzt einfach das mehl kurzum damit ich
wieder die glasschüssel drunter stellen
kann
ihr müsst das zuhause natürlich nicht
machen und jetzt droht
jetzt ist es zu ende die maschine hatte
frank hoch an
also man hat anders verläuft können sind
zu ende
ausstellung und das prüfte herrschte
jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht was es
denn überhaupt das frühstück bei
dinkelmehl ist es einfach so dass es
wohl schnell trocken werden kann und
auch nicht mehr ganz so frisch schmeckt
und deswegen stellt man dieses frühstück
her
das heißt es werde jetzt gleich
aufgebrüht mit gekochtem wasser kann
hier schon mal das wasser ansetzen was
ich jedem glas habe
[Musik]
sobald das wasser kocht kommt jetzt hier
drüber gemeinsam mit dem salz und dann
wird jetzt einfach mal alles gute
verwöhnt
[Musik]
natürlich das ganze wieder in ein
schraubglas 1
damit ist einfach luftdicht verpacken
kann damit sie nicht austrocknet kommt
ja direkt an die oberfläche eine
frischhaltefolie das ist wirklich gar
nicht austrocknet und dann verschließe
ich das ganze unglaubliche postbrief
stück und auch den sauerteig einfach
über nacht steht für etwa zwölf bis 15
stunden bei raumtemperatur
einen tag später seht jetzt der
sauerteig so aus und das frühstück so
das ganze riecht sehr gut sehr sauer und
das sehr exotisch aber es wird gleich
ein richtig leckeres brot
ich habe ich jetzt noch ein paar zutaten
um den teig herzustellen
für den teig brauche dinkel sauerteig
das ding das bruchstück hier ist noch
das übrige dinglich vollkornmehl des um
325 gramm zehn gramm salz 20 km olivenöl
und 215 krumbacher jetzt nehme ich
zuerst einmal die dreiteilige das heißt
dass bull stücke und das ist wirklich
ein ziemlich schwerer klotzen
natürlich dass es ab heute gibt es das
wort klopfen nicht zu verwechseln mit
dem glaubt fühlt wird können wir sagen
das ganze könnte jetzt entweder mit der
küchenmaschine verbänden oder auch mit
der hand und ich nehme jetzt noch ein
bisschen mehr und fährt jetzt zuerst
einmal die masse zusammenfinden
[Musik]
jetzt können die übrigen zutaten mit
rheinwasser
[Musik]
und sobald sich alles verbunden hat
kommt noch dass olivenöl imitation und
mit auch kurz ein geknetet und es ist
auch wirklich so vereinfacht
das werde ich den tag abdecken und den
abgedeckt für zwei stunden noch einmal
wohnen davon
so sieht datei gibt es nach der
wartezeit aus und jetzt habe ich hier
eine kasten backform sie nämlich 25
zentimetern länge und fette sie jetzt
mit back translate da kommt der teig
jetzt hinein und da braucht man auch auf
jeden fall eine backform denn ihr seht
ihr auch schon der teig der lässt sich
nicht formen
[Musik]
und jetzt mache ich die hände nass und
jetzt nehme ich den einen finger und
kann jetzt erstmal den rand als wie beim
diesel ikonen aktion sozusagen glatt
streichen
[Musik]
lasst euch von den geräuschen nicht
beirren
der macht den lärm und jetzt mit der
kompletten hand glatt streichen
jetzt ist der teig schön glatt und jetzt
muss ich ihnen noch mal abdecken und für
etwa 1 1 bis 1 5 stunden ruhen lassen
und die backform direkt hinter richtig
schöne massive backform de nimmt die
wärme gut auf und gibt sie auch wirklich
ganz langsam wieder ab und speichert sie
auch sehr gut gesorgt dass ich jetzt
wohnt und dann zeige ich euch gleich den
teig noch mal vor dem backen jetzt
soweit jetzt werde ich wieder einen
punkt spender nimmt und das boot mit
wasser besprüht und tri mich eine
tankkarte legte jetzt auf denn ich
möchte das brot jetzt mit mohn und auch
mit bisschen mehl bestreuen
ich habe ich jetzt musik und da habe ich
null reis drin so sorgt jetzt einfach
dafür dass das mehl nicht so schnell
durchkommt
das reicht schon jetzt habe ich den
streifen in der mitte den möchte ich es
gerne mit mehl bestreuen
und dafür lege ich einfach zwei karten
hin und jetzt kann ich die mitte mit
mehl bestreuen
und jetzt lege ich die teile ich hierhin
und bestreut hier den teils mond
[Musik]
und jetzt spricht noch mal wasser drauf
und so kommt das brot in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 42 grad für
etwa 40 minuten
und natürlich muss man vorher einen
verein legen oder ein park jetzt schauen
wir mal das gut an
da ist es schon ziemlich fertig aus ihr
seht schon das brot löst sich schon von
der backform jetzt machen wir mal die
klopp methode als er den knopf prüfung
heißt wir gehen diese theorie war und
ich stürzte ist jetzt hier kurz raus
[Musik]
das herauslösen weil es ein bisschen
schwierig ist nämlich einfach eine
palette und fühlst hier den rand das
habe ich eben schon gemacht haben kann
nichts rausbekommen
ja
[Musik]
klopp ich irgendwie ihr hört und hört
nichts das weiß ich noch ein bisschen
weich unten geht es noch mal für etwa
fünf minuten in den backofen und dann
ist das brot fertig hier kann das boot
angeschnitten werden dass pro das jetzt
gerade ein bisschen frisch noch sehr
warm ist doch zum anschneiden ja so oft
passiert dass es dann ein bisschen
schmerzen aber ich muss dazu sagen dass
ich war es erlebe das eine boot ist
übrigens immer etwas schmaleren
kastenform und das in einer etwas
breiteren gefallen und probieren ja
ich habe gesagt ja bei mohn hat man halt
den vorteil sein bis man merkt auch noch
fünf tage später das man mond brot
gegessen habe man alles voll mit mohn
und knusprig sie haben gehört dass auch
und costa geld ja und jetzt und in ein
richtig schön saftig und das kommt halt
durch diese richtig jetzt nicht gut da
jetzt das
ich war jetzt gerade im kühlschrank
nicht rechtzeitig
aber geschmacklich sehr sehr gut
kein vergleich zur gekauft im angebot
haben und es ist wirklich noch tagelang
also mindestens mit seinem zwischen drei
und fünf jahren mindestens wenn's so
lange überlebt also ist wirklich super
so wahrhaftig schön formstabil recht gut
schmeckt gut und recht hat sech wenn die
frühstück noch recht echten hasen dem
rasen muss
dekra und falls ihr das rezept sucht und
gerne nachmachen möchte dann schaut auf
meinem blog vorbei auffällig blog.de da
steht alles noch mal ganz genau
beschrieben und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß beim nachbacken ihr habt
gesehen ist es kein kunstwerk ein
meisterwerk
ihr könnt es ganz einfach nachmachen und
dazu braucht ihr nur eine hälfte
backformen also viel spaß bereiten und
bis zum nächsten mal
vom saison gelungen
[Musik]
nicht zu verwechseln mit glock für sport
können wir sagen dass ich direkt sally
dialekt sprach und klotzen aufschlossen
sprache heißt bahnkörper wort fälle ist
es noch mal für etwa fünf minuten in den
backofen und dann ist das brot fertig
kommt so sonnenblumen grund kleinen
machen
jetzt muss ich mal raus neckar machte
aus mir raus